salut je suis toujours en parc de
belleville et je suis avec tiffany et
geoffrey on va essayer de voir ce qui se
passe dans l'assiette de tiffany et ce
qui se passe à hâter d'une fille en fait
bah oui ces soucis on a vu on a vu un
but mais nous on va essayer de trouver à
quel cartel france n'est pas si évident
que ça notre but à geoffrey un mois
c'est de retrouver quel car tu as en
tête maintenant ok taquine car c'est une
seule carte santé est on a une belle
image mentale
oui super pouvez essayer de le faire
même temps que nous la première étape ça
va être de jouer sur les choses qui sont
binaires donc la rouge ou noir on va
chercher si sa carte et les rouge et
noir qui va regarder tiffany fanny tu
penses à ta carte et je vais dire rouge
noir rouge noir rouge noir en alternance
à chaque fois que je dis la couleur si
c'est rouge
aussi chic c'est noir tu penses top dans
ta tête mais justement dirais tu le dis
pas ok donc ta carte 4 litres d'eau
cartel peut être rouge noir rouge noir
rouge noir des choses entre vous deux
bonjour d'amateurs alors est ce que tu a
perçu une différence ou pas déjà de base
winants un petit peu mais je suis pas
sûr de moi je dirais que c'est quoi j'ai
noir moi je dirais que c'est noir aussi
et ces essais noir on a bon donc du coup
comme on sait que c'est noir maintenant
on va chercher entre très fluide on
garde le même méthode
ok on regarde la même est ce que tu peux
regarder vers la maintenant comme ça ils
peuvent le faire sur toi et toi tu
essaies de faire le point c'est les
chants corses
il parle de belleville pour sada carte
ça peut être très pic trèfle
réf
allez j'arrête là est ce que tu as une
idée à moi je dirais que cette pique en
l'occurrence alors je vais dire pourquoi
je pense que c'est peut-être me trompe
mais en fait la d expression je sais pas
si vous vous avez vu tu avais comme un
hochement de tête c'est très léger 1
c'est une micro expressions mais halak
et c'est quelque chose comme si elle
valide et en fait inconsciemment donc je
dirais que c'est du pic
c'est la 4ème alors c'est lui qui répond
aux caisses et puis si vous entendez il
ya quelqu'un qui chante la marseillaise
en écho en fait le débat thiel de
chanteur s'est pas égoïste mais on s'est
retourné quand même maintenant tu vas
dire toi même toutes les cartes de l'as
roy en allant le plus vite possible tu
fais 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 etc
c'est parti on t'écoute il découle 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 valait c'est parfait
je vous explique tout se passait bien
sûr déjà j'ai éliminé l'as parce que
j'étais tendu un piège grossier je t'ai
dis tu dis 1 2 3 4 5 6 et tu répètes
comme moi d'arudy un deux trois sites
avaient pris la chute aurait pas d'y
instaurer corrigé avec classe et ça tu
l'as pas fait ta clairement ralenti au
niveau du disque parce que comme je te
met un peu la pression tu as envie de
partir sur ans 12-13
mais comme ses films et a pas envie de
faire ça mais non j'ai pas une véritable
d'un ralenti et après tu as commencé à
placer les autres car tu aurais jamais
ralenti
cit avait anticipé les autres cartes et
tu les auraient anticipé si c'était ta
carte qui était le valais la dame où le
roi ou voir même de 10
donc la carte elle est située entre 2 et
9 déjà jeté un peu mâcher le travail
même avant avancé avant six mois
moi je dis ça aussi je pense avoir la
carte précisément en tête parce qu on a
raison pour le moment oui est ce que tu
veux faire un essai tu du talit pas un
tu lui confirme pas bonjour et 10 4 427
pas mal moi je suis plus chef gerry 10,2
en fait mais peut-être peut-être pas
avant jeudi rexel de putois le cas de
pics ex quoi semer quelques tentatives
de pique
il y est
merci je ferai tout et plus longs qui
arrive je te vois ça tu as pu très bien
réussi à avoir des sondés mais non mais
ouais ce que je peux encore mentalisme
non mais tu as raison en fait le vrai
pouvoir c'est de faire croire qu'on en a
parlé
tu vois en faisant ça elle va pas se
méfie toi
et là tu vas pouvoir tenir si la
prestation de geoffrey de tiffany et de
moi même vous a plu vous pouvez nous le
faire savoir grâce à un pouce en l'air
vous pouvez commenter parce que je suis
persuadé qu'ils vont lire les
commentaires en fait ils vont se presser
ils vont dire tu les commentaires pouvez
aussi vous abonner en cliquant ici dans
le coin supérieur gauche de votre écran
mais alors si je recadre on est foutu
merci beaucoup et rendez vous demain
pour le prochain mentale blog il sera à
17h ciao ciao